avec le temps plus doux la routine de
saison démarrée scheer commence
aujourd'hui on s'aime lézignan on
poursuit nos activités en essai de
peyras arnaque qui existe à rien mais
difficile d'ignorer les contrecoups de
la pandémie
déjà qu'on doit faire à part avec les
contextes de marché le contexte de météo
sauf peut-être les maps qui serait jaune
pour jacques blain qui cultive en serre
et plante chaque année une quarantaine
de variétés de légumes sur 36 hectares
le problème numéro un c'est la main
d'oeuvre étrangère qui risquent de faire
défaut
c'est programmables pathos les
travailleurs étrangers qu'on a demandé
durant arrivée est probablement avec
duras tard si certains malgré tout
braveront les craintes du coronavirus un
autre problème s'ajoute pour jacques
blain les travailleurs qu'il hébergerait
dans ce logement qui leur est dédié ne
permettra pas de respecter les mesures
de distanciation sociales et physiques
notamment pendant la quarantaine
obligatoire de deux semaines donc ça
c'est le logement pour les travailleurs
les manger c'est une chambre spectacle
avec deux lits superposés ou on peut
loger quatre personnes vous donc la
seule nouvelle directe et que j'ai dû
hier soir faudrait avoir à tout un de
battre à chaque personne alors qu'il
achève d'écouler ses produits de la
saison passée les obstacles se
multiplient contre sa production
puisqu'il n'a pas le choix d'embaucher
ces travailleurs de l'étranger
au manque de main d'oeuvre on se plante
- il ya moins de produits développés la
demande dans si la demande était encore
en informant de produire de souffre et
la demande les prix vont augmenter
c'est d'ailleurs le cas récemment
reconnaît l'un des plus importants
grossistes au canada est ce que ça va
changer un petit peu au niveau de
l'offre la demande oui le monde
cherchent des produits de base ça on a
vu beaucoup de demandes au niveau des
produits pommes de terre oignons
carottes les produits de salades mais
c'est notamment à cause des produits qui
viennent de l'extérieur sans lakovic 19
les taux de change aurait resté plus
stable en attendant d'ici cinq semaines
les experts vont sortir de terre ici la
solution embaucher de la main d'oeuvre
locale non formés jacques blais n'a
d'ailleurs jamais reçu autant de cv sauf
que c'est un travail qui n'apparaît pas
mais très difficile d'être que la main
d'oeuvre vouloir persister dit mais
plusieurs qui viennent essayer au
printemps puis après deux jours il ya
pendant ne travaille pas c'est trop
difficile face au défi il faut rester
optimiste à court terme le monde panique
un petit peu à moyen terme je crois que
ça risque de se placer mais pour
l'instant le casse-tête des récoltes est
loin d'être résolue pour les maraîchers
falloir trouver des solutions auront
besoin d aide à ce niveau là c'est
peut-être là que la solution led
pourrait venir le niveau de la
logistique organisationnel
d'un naturel lui aussi optimiste jaglin
fait malgré tout préparer les caisses
qui accueilleront ces légumes récoltés
prochainement afin espère t-il de
nourrir d'abord et avant tout des
québécois ici frédéric arnould
radio-canada comme tonnes en estrie